il ya cent ans jour pour jour un jeune
auteur tremblant du nom d'edmond rostand
assisté à la première représentation de
sa pièce cyrano de bergerac et des
dizaines de rappels des ovations ont
marqué le premier triomphe de ce
chef-d'oeuvre qui continue d'émouvoir et
d'enchanter un peu partout dans le monde
geneviève moll sur cette scène du
théâtre de la porte saint-martin à paris
il y as exactement 100 ans
coquelin aîné était le premier
interprète de cyrano de bergerac à la
fin de la pièce le public est debout
l'auteur à peine connue acquiert une
célébrité inouïe
il a 29 ans il s'appelle edmond rostand
depuis tous les grands comédiens ont
voulu interpréter cyrano 1432 alexandra
à dire dans tous les registres agressif
moi je réponds pas le nail frais sont le
changement passe amical mzimba trempé
dans votre terrasse pour boire
faites vous fabriquez un âne ap monsieur
petit pas dramatique cela mais rose
quand il s'est dans ce métier très long
métrage détruit là où il en rougit
lefebvre l'amour si un os défigurée par
son nez en et dévorer comme n'importe
quel jeune premier un baiser mais à tout
prendre
est ce un serment fait d'un peu plus
près une promesse plus précises un aveu
qui veut se confirmer un point fraude
chrome est sûre lit du verbe aimer
et c'est fort c'est la plus belle du
soir je m'exerce j'oublie et j'aperçois
soudain l'ombre de mon profil sur le
bureau du charme
amoureuse éperdue que rémy ne m'entendre
mais bretteur intrépide et bravache
cyrano est devenu un archétype un
exemple d'humanité